[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
another sort of rant video now as you
guys know i kind of stayed away from the
sort of underwhelming event that was ces
2012. a lot of the you know a lot of the
products introduced were cool and it's
nice to go to ces but a lot of the stuff
was just like incremental upgrades you
know the droid razer max which is
slightly better than the razer and the
the transformer prime tf700t which is
slightly better than the current
transformer prime so overall i know a
lot of you guys might agree and if you
hit thumbs up i'll probably already know
you guys agree a lot of products
introduced there were just okay but i
have a confession
there was
one thing one product at ces 2012 that
caught my eye and that was the lg
55-inch oled tv
wow like okay here was my reaction
when i say i want this like i don't
think you understand this this is it
forget forget the 3d technology that was
introduced in last year's ces tvs that
was kind of the thing to throw into tvs
but this year this is the stuff that i
actually want to see in fact go ahead
and take a look at some of this video
this was taken by
austin from duncan33303 and it shows a
lot of the really cool features of it as
you can see the tv looks absolutely
absurd it looks really really thin it
looks the bezel you can see there's
practically no bezel it's absurdly good
looking the contrast is really high the
blacks are pitch black so the image that
you get on the screen is is really
really beautiful really really rich and
the tv is also probably for the really
really rich but yeah it is a nice tv now
remember the video i did a little while
back on oled technology and why it rocks
remember the video i did on the samsung
galaxy nexus's oled display just for
that remember the video i did with the
zune hd oled display yeah in case you
haven't noticed oled is awesome oled
devices actually tend to be very very
thin and tend to look really really good
every single time so i kind of proposed
in those videos that you know every cell
phone manufacturer should just use oled
technology in all their cell phones
because it's also really low power it
doesn't like black pixels at all and
that saves battery life and makes low
power devices so i'm
proposing i really okay i just really
hope that oled tvs catch on and as you
guys know when stuff catches on
competition is great and that's what's
going to have companies pitting against
each other and trying to undercut prices
and deliver the best goods with the
lowest price so that's what's going to
drive prices straight down straight down
to the like button on this video until
eventually we have say 24 inch oled
monitors just for the same price that we
have 24 inch lcd monitors right now you
might have seen a recent rumor from
technobuffalo it was regarding the apple
sort of itv rumor and uh among the specs
that were presented in that article were
that it might be an oled display uh even
if i don't want to buy necessarily an
apple tv i want them to introduce that
to the market because as you know when
apple introduces something kind of new
then other companies are kind of just on
their tail like a wildfire that didn't
make any sense but the trend spreads and
eventually you've got oled tvs
everywhere and that's what we want
because then the competition starts and
prices go down honestly these tvs look
so great that i am definitely going to
be trying my hardest to get some of
these in-house and reviewing as many of
these as possible for you guys and hey
if apple starts under maybe say two
thousand dollars i might seriously
consider
that one
but honestly i really hope this market
explodes
in a good way either way this has been
an mkbhd rant video it's kind of turned
into a sort of positive rant video so
again if you like this video to show
that you agree that would really help it
also really helps me out as you guys can
see i am replying to your comments down
below uh what i want to know is what do
you think of this oled technology uh
craze or sort of introduction the 3d
that was kind of thrown into tvs last
year didn't really get a very welcome
response so i'm interested to see what
you guys think about oled stuff in the
new tvs either way thanks for watching
and share this video if you enjoy it and
i'll talk to you guys later
[Music]
you